okay question question since you're an
avatar fan Legend of chord do you rate
it I think if they were told that they
they were meddled a lot right yeah I
think it could have been so much better
but I think there's some good parts in
Coral like yeah I like the first season
but then I found the ending was kind of
rushed almost yeah it was kind of like
okay all right doesn't matter no I mean
I haven't seen her but it doesn't really
matter too much before you watch
something never no why wouldn't we do
that okay
do you do that I remember now this is
last time last summer
you're like nah I'm getting like [ __ ]
Vietnam flashback except the last time
we recorded an anime podcast together
and you said you read spoilers before
you watch the show Tony not the
destination I am a firm believer of like
if I know what happens it doesn't
detract from my viewing experience
because either way I'm watching it but
why not have the experience of like say
being able to watch it but then you of
not knowing what's gonna happen
yeah the anxiety
do you get anxiety reading the spoilers
as it's going on but sometimes but like
when I read this book I'm like oh That's
How It Ends oh that's how the conflict
is resolved I feel much better let me
enjoy and watch this now you know but
you already know what it's going to be
before you watch it yeah this has like
divorced parent energies like I just
wish I could know when they'd stop
fighting when will they like I just want
to know I had a crystal ball that could
literally tell me anything I wanted to
know I would take it like I want to know
when I die because how I die when my
dog's gonna die like when like what do
you want to do what do you want to know
I could treasure every day
so I'm just gonna like piss my life away
or whatever
it's nice the information is nice you
know what would have happened if I like
went this route in my career with this
or whatever you like let me know
everything let's say if like life this
Crystal Ball told you that you were
gonna fail you'd be like well why am I
trying then right
in that case if you just knew everything
that was going to happen because
everything's predetermined in that case
yeah but they still like I can still
experience it right just because I know
like oh I'm going to drink a lot here
and have fun but I'm still gonna drink
and have fun
so you don't like surprises is what I'm
hearing yeah I guess there's some
knowing stuff it's anxiety I don't know
there was one time we went to watch a
scary movie yeah and I just I could not
take it I wanted to take out my phone
and read the spoilers
okay okay actually actually I was going
to say there is one case where I do just
read and watch spoilers horror movies
horror movies
like that because okay I'm I'm an actual
I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] when it comes to
horror movies I'll be honest like I hate
not knowing what's going to happen but
like but like at the same time I think a
lot of horror movie concepts are just
really [ __ ] interesting yeah so I
like I I watch more videos breaking down
horror movie spoilers than I actually
watch horror movies Sydney's gonna
[ __ ] kill me because she [ __ ]
loves horror movies but I I I I think I
know like most horror movies like the
plot of most big horror movies I think I
get what you mean like I've seen an
arduous amount of like would you be able
to survive this saw trap video more than
the actual song right like I haven't
seen a single Saw movie but God damn I
want to know how you'd Escape right
because like horror movies have some of
the best hooks of like any films like
you you can boil it down to like one
tagline or one like it's basically a
YouTube clickbait you know it's got like
the interesting concept but like I don't
want to experience like the [ __ ] of
like getting scared and getting jump
scared right and all that [ __ ] oh that
reminds me of my other favorite anime um
you know movie Recaps on YouTube yeah I
watch that so much like I don't even
watch movies anymore I watch movies you
have the same brain as God God does the
exact same thing hello there what should
we recap here today I'm going to tell
you a story about blah blah blah blah
uh no I'm just I just like your accent
okay is this like an accurate yeah I've
I've never related to someone so hard
because I I thought I was a psychopath
so really you guys should try it it's
good bedtime stories you just put one on
and then you just like you you listen to
someone explain the movie plot yeah you
don't need to spend two hours watching
the movie no I I totally get that with
movies that's why art is dead
I don't know why I watch YouTube videos
at 1.5 speeds you know you you don't
even yeah
but like no I totally get that with like
movies that I say like really [ __ ] up
where it's like oh really [ __ ] for
example it's like yeah okay I'll watch a
guy breaking down a movie but if it's
like do you do that with all movies even
ones that you look at and you're like oh
that looks interesting no not all movies
yeah most of like most movies are like I
think in like the let's say the six to
seven out of ten range if it's a Marvel
movie you're gonna watch it depends on
the Marvel movie
yeah that's my favorite anime
but like but like sometimes I just I
have certain Marvel movies that I want
to watch and experience the fullest but
like I don't want to watch all the
[ __ ] that comes before like for
example when I watch when I'm going to
watch Doctor Strange I don't want to
[ __ ] watch One Division I'll just
watch someone's summary of one division
is not a bad TV show
did you did you watch the new Doctor
Strange movie I did did you like it
um okay so there are so many elements
that I really like the horror elements
were fantastic and there were some
really cheesy lines yeah it was some
really cheesy I've actually spoiled
myself on the doctor strange movie
because of this guy actually I just
watched everything everywhere all at
once yeah that's nice
that's not something I'm going to spoil
for myself that's like um that's the one
movie I didn't spoil myself yeah because
like I watch it
so good right amazing okay because I
have like certain movies where I'm like
I want to experience this the fullest I
want to not spoil myself and then some
of them I'm just like eh whatever I just
I just want to know what happens like
what yeah like like when you say Doctor
Strange was like mid I was like okay
well okay yeah yeah no more views is a
perfect example of like I'll just go and
watch a recap yeah yeah because like I'm
not gonna go [ __ ] walk I'm not I'm
not even gonna watch a [ __ ] recap
I only watched the recap so I could
understand the memes more I really
thought they said It's morphin time in
the movie yeah I thought so too I don't
say it I I thought so as well I thought
that was an actual line that people were
mean for the longest time I thought oh
it's just a line in the movie it's just
it's that bad yeah I really thought I
just love the idea of just just memeing
these really terrible movies and giving
like the executive is like wow people
love this movie everyone's talking about
if they don't say it's morbin time in
morbius too oh we've thoroughly just
directed to TV right it's direct to
Apple TV it's not going in like it's not
it's not a cinematic
the second movie is not going to be a
theatrical that's going to be a second
one yeah
why would they do that one was so
popular but like look at Google Trends
yeah but like didn't they like who who
produced it against Sony I think it was
Sony that producer didn't they like
re-release it because of the memes yeah
Cinemas and then it [ __ ] bombs yeah
they're although people want to see this
because it's everyone's talking about it
let's re-release it [ __ ] bombs like
so I'm surprised they're doing a second
one honestly I don't know how it's gonna
work it's not that's the thing no the
first one didn't work how do you turn
off the first one oh my God so have you
ever read like a spoiler to like a TV
show or a movie and you've kind of like
regretted it has that ever happened
never what literally never I just enjoy
media differently oh my gosh
reminds me of Harry Potter I think Harry
Potter he's Australian I'm not even
British that's the most I just want to
segue into like I think Harry Potter
should be an anime
uh yeah I mean so what makes you think
this is Academia that's basically Harry
Potter yeah
it's Harry Potter with little girls
that's all it is
I mean it's got the vibe down but it's
not exactly Harry Potter it's more
cutesy than Harry Potter obviously yeah
yeah oh yeah we've always had I haven't
watched all of them I had I got up to
Goblet of Fire what the [ __ ] okay so I
haven't watched characters so I've won
half of them okay so I've watched up to
Goblin or fire and then I skipped to the
last movie
how you'd even have your citizenship
what the hell no because like to me like
I was never that obsessed with Harry
Potter I swear I've met more Americans
that are like really into Harry Potter
than I have Brits yeah yeah I like um
you know how an avatar it's like oh what
element are you yeah Harry Potter what
house are you like I like things like
that you know I like to compartmentalize
my friends into categories in my brains
so we are just the British guys then I
guess element yeah and Avatar like
whatever [ __ ] I don't know a Harry
Potter I'm a Slytherin oh in Harry
Potter I'm a Hufflepuff everyone's a
Hufflepuff everyone how do you know what
house you are there's a official quiz
you can do oh is that yeah I haven't
done that how's everyone doing
because everyone knows at least one over
[ __ ] enthusiastic Harry Potter yeah